in this video I want to talk about what
I would eat if I was diagnosed with
covid-19
coronavirus well the first thing to know
about that is that the pre-existing
conditions greatly increase your risk of
not just in the susceptibility to
getting the virus but in the
complications and even the death rate
I'm talking about diabetes heart disease
high blood pressure insulin resistance
and obesity these are the big ones
there's other ones too but all of these
have a common denominator High insulin
and I'm talking about Diabetes Type 2
right here and there's a very simple way
to deal with this okay
what you do is you go on a low carb diet
okay and we're talking
the ketogenic diet moderate protein high
fat High fats in the diet are totally
fun to do as long as you keep your
carbohydrates low and of course I always
recommend the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet I put a link down below
if you want to know what that is and how
to do it getting on the diet will
greatly help support healthy insulin
levels now the other things I would do
I would start to consume food high in
zinc and I just want to say that
anything I say in this video is not
meant to diagnose or replace your
medical care or provide a treatment for
the coronavirus check with your doctor
before taking any of this advice there's
a huge association between having enough
zinc in your body and having your immune
system work properly almost at every
single level of your immune defenses
zinc is involved and if you wanted to
know what foods are highest in zinc
oysters are the number one food other
shellfish would be another option red
meat cheese there's other foods but
these have probably the most zinc zinc
is very very important in supporting a
healthy thymus gland and the thymus is a
training camp for certain immune cells
so it's very very important and if
you're deficient in zinc your thymus
actually shrinks the next thing I would
do is make sure I have enough vitamin D
you can get that in cod liver oil
salmon
fatty fish
but it's very very difficult to consume
foods and get the amount of vitamin D
that you need so I would highly
recommend getting enough Sun 20 minutes
every single day would give you enough
vitamin D because vitamin D is what's
called an immune modulator so it keeps
the immune system from overreacting
where you have so much inflammation and
collateral damage it could damage your
lungs and other tissues so vitamin D is
very very important in keeping the
immune system at a balanced level
certain viruses have a strategy of
blocking the receptor for vitamin D
taking enough vitamin D can actually
override that so you can keep that
immune support at a high level and then
you have vitamin C very important in
supporting a healthy immune system
especially dealing with viruses leafy
greens will give you a lot of vitamin C
sauerkraut if you actually make your own
sauerkraut or get a high quality
sauerkraut from either a farmer's market
or the office store
you could get a tremendous amount of
vitamin C sometimes 700 milligrams and
really all you need is between 70 to 90
milligrams as the RDA so now of course
that doesn't account for all types of
sauerkraut because there's different
versions but I'm just talking at the
high end we're starting at 700 and it's
probably going to go down from there
berries are a good source of vitamin C
as well there's a lot of other foods
that have vitamin C but the more you
cook foods or your canned foods you lose
not just vitamin C and vitamin D but
zinc two canned foods will deplete the
effectiveness of zinc by 85 percent and
by the way if you think that you're
going to consume like orange juice for
your vitamin C you're mistaken because
they pasteurize or use high temperatures
and cook the orange juice that destroys
the vitamin C the vitamin C that you
would have in that orange juice is
usually coming from an added
static version of vitamin C called
ascorbic acid and it's my opinion that
is definitely not the same as the
vitamin C that comes from actual fruits
and vegetables and lastly let's talk
about this thing called stress
I know it might be hard to believe but
some people are actually
stressed out nowadays now stress
increases cortisol
cortisol chronically elevated as in
long-term stress can severely affect
your immune system it causes your
lymphatic system to shrink it makes your
lymph nodes decrease it decreases the
antibody production so you lose your
ability to fight infection it also
greatly increases your susceptibility to
getting viruses and bacteria I would
actively and aggressively do what I can
to keep stress at a minimum and that
would definitely include not watching
the news so much because there are so
many messages that are all about Doom
and Gloom bad news over and over and
over fear fear fear guess what that does
to the immune system it really makes the
person way more susceptible to getting
the infection as compared to not being
in that state of worry and anxiety if
you actually trace it back to right
before they got that infection
I would say nearly 100 of the time they
had a stress event stress is a huge
trigger to not only being susceptible to
viruses but activating viruses that are
already inside your body this explains
why people when they get stressed they
have shingles they get herpes they get
all sorts of other health problems we
have getting on the right diet to
minimize these conditions right here
eating foods high in the three most
important nutrients and lowering stress
and lastly if you haven't seen my videos
on the nutrients or these conditions
here I put the videos up right here
check them out